Okay.
The Gospel of Matthew
from the second century on has been
pretty much the most popular famous of the
Gospels.
That's probably why it's first in our
Bible simply because it was the most
popular,
the most popular.
It certainly the gospel that's
most familiar to people nowadays.
And uh,
pretty much throughout history of people
were familiar with the text at all,
both Christians and non Christians often.
So for example,
you have the familiar birth story.
Joseph has a dream. He's warned,
uh, the star appears in
the east, the mad jai,
the wise men come and they go to
Herod first. This is not, yes,
this is Herod the Great.
So they're going to Herod the Great's
palace in Jerusalem and they say,
where do we find this new king that's
been born because we want to go and
worship him and bring him gifts.
Inherited gets all worried because he
doesn't want to lose his own throne.
So I remember this story.
He tells the Weizmann, well,
I think you have to go to
Bethlehem. He gets his, his uh,
Wiseman who's own Wiseman,
they look it up in the scriptures.
They say go to Bethlehem, but he's
come back and tell me once you visited,
because I want to go worship him too.
And the wicked evil king does not want
to go worship Jesus, the baby Jesus.
He wants to go kill the baby.
Jesus.
The wise men are warned in a dream not
to go back. Do you know the story? Right?
The whole thing about that.
The Egyptian sojourn,
the holy family goes to Egypt
to escape the wicked king.
The slaughter of the innocence,
uh,
the beatitudes blessing are the poor
in spirit for theirs is the Kingdom of
Heaven. Blessed are those who
mourn for they will be comforted.
Blessed are the meek for they will
inherit the earth. All these blessings,
there are some in Luke,
but if you,
if you start saying them and somebody
starts picking it up after you and repeats
it and they shows that they
at least know it enough to,
they can kind of finish
one every now and then,
they almost always finish it in the
Matthew form, not the Luke form.
The be attitudes are slightly different
in Matthew and Luke and people are,
they're famous in their methy
inform, uh, turn the other cheek.
That's also in Luke six 29,
but most people know it from
Matthew Five 39 in Matthew,
the Pharisees are called over and
over again, hypocrites. And in fact,
if you look up the word Pharisee in
a dictionary in English dictionary,
hypocrite will be one of the definitions
you, you'll find for it. Now,
this is all part of this is long,
long tradition of Christian antisemitism.
Because of course the word Pharisee
doesn't mean hypocrite to most Jews,
the WHO trace back rabbinic Judaism to
the priest, 70 pharisees themselves.
Gamaliel in book of acts is considered
a pharisee and he's a famous rabbi in
rabbinic materials. So Jews don't think
of the word Pharisee as being a bad term,
but in a lot of English and
a lot of languages, it is
because Christians used it.
They took it straight out of Matthew
where the Pharisees are called hypocrites
over and over again, and they just
take that into their own language.
And then you have the Great Commission
that ends the Gospel of Matthew that
people might recognize.
Matthew 28 18 Jesus meets the
disciples in Galilee after his,
after his resurrection,
and he says,
all authority in Heaven and
on earth has been given to me.
Go therefore and make
disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and the Holy Spirit and
teaching them to obey everything that
I've commanded you. And remember,
I am with you always
to the end of the ages.
So that's a very famous verse that is
called the Great Commission because this
is Jesus telling his disciples
after his resurrection,
go out and proclaim the gospel throughout
the earth, not just to the Jews.
So all these things make Matthew look
very familiar even to people who may not
know much about Christianity because this
stuff that you see in our culture over
again,
Matthew,
therefore is in at the same
time a unfamiliar to people.
If they start reading it carefully because
it's the most Jewish of the Christian
Gospels and the Gospel and
that are in the Canon. That is,
there are some other gospels from the
ancient period that are even more Jewish
than Matthew. Uh, but they didn't
make it into the new testament.
It's the most Jewish,
and yet it's also at the same time,
one of the most universals of the
gospels because you've precisely have an
ending with Jesus commanded the apostles
to make disciples of all nations.
That is all the gentiles too. So
Jesus, in the gospel of Matthew,
Jesus limits his ministry during
his lifetime, pretty much to Israel.
He's going to Jews and he makes this a
point of this and the gospel of Matthew.
But after his resurrection,
then the message is supposed to go out.
Okay.
So look also at the way that
Matthew begins, I talked about this,
the very first lecture of class.
Matthew begins with the book
of the Genesis of Jesus Christ,
son of David,
son of Abraham.
So notice he calls him son of David as a
descendant of the great king of Israel.
Son of Abraham is the father of the Jews.
And even the word, the Greek word there,
the book of the Genesis,
the genesis means the beginning.
And of course it's the Greek term that
was given for the first book of the
Hebrew Bible when the, when they
translated the Hebrew Bible in degree,
genesis just means the beginning,
of course in the Hebrew
Bible is the beginning of the
world, beginning of earth,
the beginning of history.
Matthew appropriates that term and he
begins his own text with that same word,
probably meaningful his readers to
recall the book of Genesis in a way.
And then you have what you,
what we call an Aga da on Moses.
The Term Aga is used in
rabbinic scholarship.
Okay.
Rabbinics, uh, work often divides up
a lot of event materials into Halakha.
And Aga Halaqah refers to the teachings
that are about how you should live.
A Aga though are stories that are about
the patriarchy and great figures and
they're meant to, to make a moral
lesson or something like, but uh, they,
they don't give straightforward teachings.
They tell stories.
And that's how Matthew starts out.
All that stuff about the bay evil king
wanting to kill the baby Jesus because
he's afraid that it'll be a threat to him.
Uh,
people think of who does that
remind you of? Who does that
sound like? Uh, the, the,
the child that comes out of Egypt,
who does that sound like?
These are all meant to remind
you of Moses. And so Moses,
Jesus is portrayed over and over again
like Moses are like Joseph also from the
Hebrew Bible.
And then again,
you have the fulfillment
of scripture motif.
Now notice that in spite of the fact
though that Mo Matthew has throughout
Christianity been interpreted as
actually a rejection of the law,
the Jewish law,
or it presents Jesus as a new Moses,
but Christians so often taken that to
say that Jesus is not only the new Moses
who can fulfill his Moses,
he displaces the old Moses.
So Matthew's may have
been put first in the, uh,
Canon because it was read by Christians
as being sort of almost like the new
law,
the new Torah.
And so you have Jesus talking about
the law, the Jewish law Torah,
and also giving New Commandments.
Christian Christians have taken that
to mean the displacement of the Jewish
Torah with now a new Christian Torah.
And that's,
and that that actually then puts
Matthew in a very odd position.
It's the of the different
gospels in our Canon.
It's the most Jewish looking and sounding,
and I'll emphasize that
later in the lecture today,
but Matthew has also been the source of
some of the worst Christian antisemitism
precisely by portraying Jesus as rejecting
the law of Moses in much of Christian
interpretation and
substituting his own law.
That's a Christian antisemitism.
A notice it's from, as I said,
is from Matthew that you get the idea that
hip, the Pharisees are all hypocrites.
And then that gets transferred to
being that all Jews are hypocrites.
You get the idea in Christianity
traditionally that Jesus rejected the law
because that's legalism.
The Jews are all legalistic and we
Christians are awful of grace and truth.
So this idea that,
uh,
that the old testament represents a god
of anger and a god of strictness and a
God of judgment and the New Testament
represents a god who's a father and loving
and full of grace. So this dualism
that so much part of European history,
even common sense,
even people who are not religious will
often come up with this caricature that
the Old Testament God is the
god of anger and judgment.
The New Testament God is the god
of grace and forgiveness. Well,
that's just not true if you read either
testament with any care at all. But Matt,
the Gospel of Matthew has been one of
the texts. It's been used in this way.
And Remember it's in the gospel of Matthew
the that you get the most anti Jewish
and antisemitic line that's
been used throughout western.
His history when the Jews,
when pilot wants to release
Jesus from being crucified,
the people, the Jews say his
blood be upon us and our children,
that became the Christian
charge of Dia side.
The Jews were then accused of killing
God and especially in medieval Europe.
So that Matthew's in this very peculiar
place when it comes to the history of
the interpretation of the New Testament,
it is at the same time the most Jewish
of our canonical gospels in many ways.
And yet it's been used in Christian
antisemitism more than any other gospel,
possibly maybe with the gospel
of John being arrival for that.
So look at the structure of Matthew though
some people have even suggested that
Matthew is an intentionally structuring
his gospel to make it look like the
Torah,
the Jewish law,
because there are five speeches
by Jesus in Matthew. These,
these same sayings you learned about
the synoptic problem last week. Uh,
if you take a synoptic problem kind of
analysis of a lot of this stuff that are
in some of these speeches and Matthew,
they will, a lot of these sayings,
my occurred in another context and Luke
are in Mark Mathieu seems to have taken
tradition mitten materials
that were traditional Tim,
that he found either in written sources or
an oral, uh, literally, uh, oral sources.
And he combines them into five
separate speeches and some people say,
maybe he meant he meant to
reflect the five books of Torah.
The PINTA Tuque is the, is the, uh,
genesis, exodus, Leviticus, numbers.
Deuteronomy Pinot took is just
the Greek word, meaning the five.
So the first five books of Jewish
scripture or called the pentitude,
and maybe Matthew was imitating that
in making five separate speeches for
Matthew, for Jesus and his Gospel.
First chapters five through seven,
you have Jesus giving with the
famous sermon on the mount.
Then chapter 10,
you haven't given a speech to his
disciples about the mission to Israel.
So all chapter fraternity is, here's
how you're supposed to do your mission.
When you go out to preach Israel, you'll
be persecuted. This will happen. Do this,
do that.
Chapter 13 and Matthew is all parables,
the parables that would, you'd find
in different places. In Marker, Luke,
Matthew kind of groups them
into one chapter and had,
and has Jesus kind of give it as one sort
of speech. He likes neatness like this.
If you look at chapter 18, it's another
speech by Jesus again to his disciples.
And this one is mainly about church rules.
Jesus talks about when your neighbor
does something that you don't like,
you go to their neighbor first,
try to settle it peaceably.
If you're neighbor won't
receive you or won't settle,
take it to the church and let the church
handled it, you know, that sort of thing.
So Jesus is giving instructions
about how the church should be,
should behave itself,
and what the Church would be like.
And then vert chapters 23 through 25,
you get a very long speech by Jesus,
which includes a big synoptic sermon.
Remember last time I talked about mark
13 and about Jesus's prophecies of,
of all this happening, uh, when
the end of time would come in,
the Messiah would swoop
down in the clouds.
Matthew takes over that speech
from mark where he finds it.
He adds a lot of materials on his own.
He also brings it up to date.
Cause remember I talked about last time,
mark didn't explicitly tell us about the
destruction of Jerusalem and his gospel.
You'll find that when we
get to Matthew and Luke,
they they put more stuff in there that
shows they were writing after the time of
mark and using mark as a source.
So that's all in that chapter.
But then there's all these long
woes to the scribes and Pharisees,
woe to the blah, blah,
blah, woe to you do this.
There's a whole section of that speech,
so five different speeches
that some scholars who even
suggested may be designed
to imitate the five
books of the Pentateuch.
But as I said,
the ending of Matthew is universalizing.
It takes this Israelite vision that you've
seen all the way through the book and
then university realizes
it to the whole world.
So it's a universalism to all that is
firmly anchored in Judaism and the Torah.
But what does the Torah,
the law mean in Matthew?
Look at five 17 I hope you
did bring your bibles member.
We're all bringing our bibles to class
all the time because you have to check me
out.
Most Christians are taught and most
people just under the influence of
Christianity have the idea that what
Christianity is is the super session of
Judaism. The thing that makes
Jews and Christians alike,
they both worship the same God.
One of the things that makes them
different is not only the the worship by
Christians of Jesus, but also the
neglect by Christians of the Jewish law.
So Christians can eat shellfish. Bacon,
pork, don't have to keep the sabbath.
Is that the view of the law we find in
Matthew five 17 do not think that I have
come to abolish the law or the prophets.
I have come not to abolish,
but to fulfill. For truly, I tell you,
until heaven and earth pass away,
not one letter,
not one stroke of the letter will pass
from the law until all is accomplished.
Now,
in a lot of Christian doctrine,
what you're taught is that Jesus did
fulfill the law in his own person,
but that's not what he says here.
Notice until heaven and earth pass away.
That's what he's talking about,
the fulfillment of it. Therefore,
whoever breaks one of the least of these
commandments and teaches others to do
the same will be called least
in the Kingdom of heaven.
But whoever does them and teaches them
will be called great in the Kingdom of
Heaven.
For I tell you,
unless your righteousness exceeds
that of the scribes and Pharisees,
you will never enter the Kingdom
of heaven. So Jesus is not saying,
okay, I've come now you don't
have to keep the Jewish law.
He's actually teaching his
own disciples and member.
If Matthew didn't want this as a
message to the members of his church,
he wouldn't put it in his gospel.
One of the things that I'm trying to
teach you in my lectures is what does it
mean to do an exegesis of this text?
Because you're going to have to write
x Jesus of your own and there's Friday
your sexually is, we'll walk you
through how to write an x Jesus paper.
But there are a couple of
things that is not extra Jesus.
It is not exit to try to figure
out what actually happened.
Did Jesus actually say this?
Uh,
Digi is actually believe that that's
part of the historical Jesus quest,
which we'll talk about later
on in the semester too. ButX
, Jesus doesn't do that.
Extra juice doesn't assume you're trying
to read the text to get behind the text
for something that happened in history,
nor does x, x, Jesus tried to figure out,
is this true or not?
It's we don't care if it's true or not.
In an next Jesus class,
what we want to do is what did the writer,
what was the writer trying
to do with this text?
We have to imagine yourself
in an ancient context.
What would he have been saying to members
of his own Christian community in the
first century?
So this obviously means that we read this
text is not Jesus necessarily teaching
this. We don't know yet where the
judge has actually taught this.
Matthew could have gotten it from some
written source from some oral sores.
I could've just made it up.
We'll talk about that problem later
when we talk about the historical Jesus
right now, we're not going to concern
ourselves. We're just gonna say,
Matthew could have written this,
but we're trying to figure out what
did Matthew you want to do with it?
Woke this text,
admit to them,
and obviously it means this rider believes
that the proper Gospel and the proper
church should be a law abiding church.
He acts,
he's expecting people in his church not
to do away with the Jewish law. Look,
um, at the, uh,
antitheses we call these the
Mathian antitheses five 21.
You have heard that it was
said to those of ancient times,
you shall not murder and murder and
whoever murdered shall be liable to
judgment.
But I tell you that the time of the
law is over and it's okay to murder.
That's not what it says,
right? What does it say?
Just shout it out.
What?
Don't even be angry.
If you are angry with a brother or sister,
you will be liable to judgment. And
if you insult a brother, sister, do,
it'd be a lab to the council. If you say,
you fool, you'll be liable to hell. Fire.
A lot of us are in trouble.
He's not saying I'm not. I'm getting
rid of the law murders. Okay, now
keep going. Uh, to the next,
where am I?
Five 27.
You have heard that it was said you
shall not commit adultery. But I say,
that's okay. Adultery
just fine. No, he says,
but I say to you that everyone who
looks at a woman with lust has already
committed adultery with her
in its heart. Wait, what?
MMM,
well, I'm gay, so I'm okay about that.
But a lot of guys are in a lot of trouble.
He's basically saying, no,
not only is adultery not okay,
even desiring her if she
belongs to the man is not okay.
That's not getting rid of the law.
Look at five 38.
You have heard it was said an eye
for an eye and a tooth for a tooth.
But I say do not resist an evil doer. If
anyone's strikes you on the right cheek,
turn the other. Also, if anyone
wants to sue you, take your coat.
Give your cloak as well. If anyone forces
you to go one mile, go the second mile.
Give it to everyone who begs from you
and you're not refuse anyone who wants to
borrow anything from you.
These antitheses had been read throughout
Christian history by many people as as
implying that Jesus is doing a way with
this bad strict legalism of the Jewish
law and he's teaching you a law
of grace instead and forgiveness.
But that's not what's going in here going
on here, right? What Jesus has done,
he's not doing away with the law here.
He's intensifying it.
If it's hard not to commit adultery,
and believe me, for a lot of people,
it is hard not to commit adultery.
It's even harder not to lust if
it's hard not to murder someone.
And if you knew some of the people
who I have to work with around here,
you'd know that it is hard
not to murder someone.
It's even harder not
to be angry with them.
And if it's hard not to retaliate,
when someone knocks you down,
it's even harder to let
them knock you down again.
Jesus has intensifying the Jewish Torah
and it making it almost impossible to
keep, but he's still expecting
his disciples to keep it.
So what Matthew presents Jesus is
doing is not getting rid at all of uh,
uh, the Torah, the Jewish law. He's
intensifying it. Now there is one place,
there are a couple of places where
it sounds like Jesus is going again.
So when the, you have a hand washing
incident. Okay, let's look at that.
And that's in 15 chapter 15,
verse 17.
[inaudible]
well, I think I have to
start getting a bit. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We start being a little bit earlier.
Where is it? Yeah. The very
first part of the chapter,
the Pharisees scribes come to
Jesus in Jerusalem and said,
why do your disciples break the tradition
of the elders for they do not wash
their hands before they eat?
He answered them,
but why do you break the commandment?
And he goes on to this sort of thing.
And he basically says that they're not
keeping the law perfectly themselves.
That they should keep it a better.
Verse 10, he said to the crowd,
uh, he called the crowd to
him and said to them, listen,
understand it is not what goes into
the mouth that defiles a person.
It is what comes out of the
mouth that defiles the person.
Now in Mark's version of
this story right around here,
mark adds a little sentence.
I remember when I talked about Marquis,
he gives you little clues that you're
really supposed to pay attention and hear
mark is a little parents setical
comment. He says, by saying this,
Jesus declared all foods clean.
In other words,
mark does a good little
gentile Christianity move.
He takes this saying of Jesus and he says,
Jesus was declared all foods clean,
so we don't have to keep kosher.
Matthew doesn't do that.
He saw that sentence in mark, but you
eat this whole chapter, that sentence,
which Matthew News and mark is not
in Matthew. Matthew took that out.
Why? Because he didn't want Matt, uh,
Jesus to declare all foods
clean because in his gospel,
Jesus teaches that Christians have to
continue keeping the law. So he does.
Matthew has Jesus disagree with
the scribes? And Pharisees,
but what he says here is that
it's much more important. Sure.
Keeping Kosher may be important,
but it's much more important what's
going on in your heart and your mind.
It's much more important what you say. So
Jesus spiritualizes in a way or, or he,
he again, he intensifies the
law and he's saying, yeah,
it's important to wash your hands.
Perhaps that, but that's not a big deal.
It's important to pay attention to kosher,
but that's not a big deal.
He makes it a moral lesson that's not anti
Jewish. That's not at all. You kind of,
you have all kinds of Hebrew prophets
in the old testament doing that kind of
stuff all over the place
saying things like,
God doesn't want just your sacrifice.
He wants your heart.
This is the way Jesus is it preventative
Matthew is just like a Jewish prophet
and Israel like Prophet
whose intensifying the law,
who giving it a moral teaching, but he
never teaches anything about giving it up.
Then also,
mmm,
Jesus.
Though also,
besides being the one who teaches about
Torah and he's being presented as Moses,
a Matthew presents Jesus more than any
other gospels as the founder of the
church. In fact, if you,
you'd look for the word Church and some
of the gospels is very hard to find it
because it's anachronistic.
Jesus didn't go around his own life
talking about the church the church
developed after his death,
but Matthew Retro rejects that
conversation about the church and even the
foundation of the church and sort of
laws about the church into the mouth of
Jesus.
Look at chapter 16 verse 17 and this is
one we already read very carefully in
mark the same story.
Yeah.
Remember in Mark Jesus says to the
disciples, who do people say that I am?
And Peter says, well, so
they pitch to some of them,
say the Lij or some of them say
one of the profits or something,
say John the Baptist and just said, but
who do you say that I am? And Peter says,
you're the Messiah. And
Jesus tells him, be quiet.
And then Jesus rebukes him.
When Peter tells him that he's
not supposed to be crucified.
Matthew takes that story again from mark,
but notice how Matthew changes it.
Uh, verse 13, when Jesus came up in
the district sensory of Philippi,
he asked his disciples,
who do you say that I am?
You get the story again and Jesus. But
when Simon Peter says, you're the Messiah,
the son of the living God,
look what Jesus says in verse 17.
Now in Matthew's version, remember
in March version, Jesus said, okay,
don't tell anybody. Jesus said
to him, blessed are you Simon,
son of Jonah for flesh and blood
has not revealed this to you,
but my father in heaven and I tell
you, you are Peter. And on this rock,
I will build my church and the
gates of hades will not prevail. It,
I will give you the keys of the Kingdom
of Heaven and whatever you bind on earth
will be bound in heaven and whatever you
loose on earth will be loosed in heaven.
Then he started to,
uh,
ordered the disciples not to tell anyone
that he was the messiah. So between the,
the,
the command to silence,
which came right after the
confession in Mark Jesus.
Matthew puts all this
foundation of the church stuff.
Now this is a very famous text that has
caused all kinds of disagreement between
Roman Catholics and Protestants.
Roman Catholics take this text as
teaching that Jesus particularly selected
Peter as the first pope. And when he says,
I'm giving you the keys of the kingdom,
it means the pope or the Bishop of Rome
is the one who has the right to bind or
loose like that Jesus
is talking about here.
Protestants rejected that interpretation
and they said, well, no, he's talking,
he's sure he's talking to Peter wants,
but you're really talking to all
the apostles. And in fact the,
the issue of binding and Loosing is not,
is given to the apostles, not just Peter.
So there's a debate among
prop between Protestants,
Roman Catholics traditionally
over this, oh, this passage,
I think the debate kind of misses the
point because I think Matthew's point is
basically just to have Jesus be the one
who found the church and puts it into
the hands of his disciples.
But that's,
that's definitely one of
the thing that Jesus does.
And then in chapter 18 is
I've already pointed out,
you have a whole chapter where Jesus
gives rules to the disciples for how the
church should be run,
how it should be organized.
But the church is also this mixed
group over and over again. Matthew,
you'll have,
uh,
you'll see a phrase that's only in Matthew
where Jesus talks about little ones.
And they also talked about
people have little faith,
but when Matthew also has a parable about
the man goes out and he strose a field
with seed and during the night his
enemy comes and so's brambles and weeds,
seeds in. And when it all
comes up, the wheat comes up.
But it's all mixed in with brambles
and thorns and weeds. And so the,
the servants, the slaves of the man
come to the master and they say,
what should we do? Should we try to
weed out all the weeds stuff? Uh,
and so we can gather the wheat into, try
to trim it all out now. And Master says,
no,
don't worry about it now.
Because if you try to pull up
all the thorns and the brambles,
you're bound to pull up
some of the wheat too.
We'll just wait until the
end until it's all ready.
And then we'll harvest the whole
thing and then we'll separate it out.
And the wheat,
we will keep it in store houses and the
brambles on Darren's will burn in hell.
So you're getting to the last little
hellfire and brimstone sermon at the end.
But the main part of the parable is that
Matthew is saying is that the world and
possibly even the church is a mixed
bag. In other words, we're not.
Everybody you see around you is
truly who you think they are.
So there are good and there's
evil mixed together, but the,
and you just got to live with that.
So the church is a,
is an organization that has uh,
uh,
both people have little faith
and people of greater faith.
It has maybe even weeds and wheat in it.
So these are all concerns of what kind of,
there's a whole group of
parables in chapter 13, uh,
that would call the mixed
group parables of Matthew.
I know their particular to Matthew because
Matthew seems to be making the point
with these mixed group parables that the
church itself is sort of a mixed group.
Another important theme of Matthew,
and I'm giving you several different
major things in Matthew cause I'm going to
ask in a moment,
why are these things here?
What does Matthew tried to do with
these different things all together?
So for example,
why is is Jesus the law giver and
still Jewish and teaches the tea,
the tea,
the acceptance of the Jewish law and yet
this universalistic message at the end
of the gospel of going to all nations.
Another thing that exit Jesus is,
is finding problems in the text and then
using the text itself to try to find
answers to those problems.
That's what exit Jesus does.
So why I'm setting up some of these themes
of Matthew because these are going to
be the problems that then I as the
wonderful scholar and Xeg that I am,
I'm going to swoop in with my angels on
the clouds of Heaven at the end of the
lecture and give you the answers to
all the problems with Matthew and then
you'll do that with your
exit use papers later.
So one of the things that Jesus says,
and also Matthew is a teacher.
Mark had told us in his gospel that Jesus
was a great teacher and people said,
wow, he's a great teacher. He teaches
not like the scribes and Pharisees.
He teaches as one with authority,
but mark didn't really tell
us much of what Jesus taught.
There are a few parables,
a few controversies,
but mark tells you that Jesus is a
great teacher without presenting Jesus'
teaching a lot. Matthew not only
tells you Jesus is a good teacher,
he presents a lot of teaching of Jesus.
And so you,
you get out a lot of that and then you
get this interesting passage in chapter
13 verse 51 turn in your hymnals to 1351
yeah.
Have you understood all this?
And this is toward the end of this
big long parable chapter member.
I told you that chapter 13 Matthew is
where Matthew puts a ton of parables.
So toward the end of this parable chapter,
Jesus asked them,
have you understood all
this? They answered yes and
he said to them, therefore,
every scribe who has been trained for
the Kingdom of Heaven is like the master
of a household who brings out of his
treasure what is new and what does old.
When Jesus had finished these parables,
he left that place.
This is a parable that
Matthew is putting in there,
I think to give a hint to his readers.
This is what Jesus was.
Jesus was a good scribe.
That's why Jesus talks about
things like you have heard it said,
but I say to you,
Jesus is taking out of the
Jewish scripture and taking
out of the Jewish law the
most important parts of it and emphasizing
those and then adding some move his
own teacher. So he's taking some
of the old and some of the new,
and that's what a good scribe is like,
but Matthew also believes that he and
his fellow disciples in his church should
be that way too.
He writes his Gospel to help people figure
out how to imitate Jesus and being a
good scribe,
how to discern what of the old you should
use and what are the new you should
use.
Yeah,
but then there's this really the one of
the last problem is I want to give is
this really big problem in Matthew
because Jesus is also something,
well,
just read on the surface.
Jesus comes across as a bit like
a coward in the gospel of Matthew.
Look at
Chapter Four Verse 12 in
Matthew Chapter Four verse 12
yeah,
first in the first part of this chapter
for you get Jesus going around preaching
the Gospel. Come in doing some
miracles in that sort of thing.
He becomes very famous so
that people hear about them.
But then you get to 12 now, when Jesus
heard that John had been arrested,
he got on his white charger and he rode
to the prison and he sprang his friend
John the Baptist out of
prison, Indiana. Jesus.
No, that's not what it says, right?
He withdrew to Galilee and
the word withdraw here is
the Greek word for retreat.
He retreated to Galilee because he
heard that John had gotten arrested.
He left Nazareth,
made his home in Capernaum by the sea in
the territory of Zebulun and Naphtali.
So that what had been spoken through
the Prophet Isaiah might be fulfilled.
And any quotes that first,
uh, 17 from that time,
Jesus began to proclaim repent for
the Kingdom of Heaven has come near.
In other words, Jesus retreats in the
face of danger. He doesn't go toward it,
but instead of retreating in hiding,
he goes to another place and then
he starts giving the message out.
This is when he really first
started his own preaching ministry.
After John the Baptist is arrested.
So notice what that happens there.
Look again at now look
at 1215 Matthew 1215
reading just a little bit above that.
Um,
okay.
Jesus is disputing with the
Pharisees and verse 14 says,
but the pharisees went out and conspired
against him. How to destroy him.
Another threat this time from
the farracies against Jesus.
Verse 15 when Jesus became aware of this,
he departed again.
He withdrew.
There's that word again.
Many crowds followed him and he cured
all of them and he ordered them not to
make him known. This was
to fulfill. Notice again,
Jesus withdraws in the face of danger,
but they're withdrawing in a sense,
increases the ministry and an
and an odd paradoxical way.
And then look at 1413
well, I won't read that one.
1413 if you can look it up,
that's another case of
danger and Jesus withdrawing.
But now let's do spend a little more time
looking at chapter 12 because have you
noticed that the gospel of Matthew likes
to foreshadow things and fulfill things?
The Gospel of Matthew likes to have Jesus
do something and then he'll tell you
something that was not in mark.
He'll say this was to fulfill the
scripture that said, for example,
when Jesus and the holy family run off to
Egypt, he then quotes to the fact that,
and they come back, he says, out of
Egypt, I will call my son a prophecy.
So Matthew takes an old
testament reference,
a a Jewish scripture
reference cause members,
not the old testament yet is just Jewish
scripture and he takes a quotation on
that and saying, is fulfilled by
Jesus? So in the same way, um,
in Matthew two 13 and 14,
after they had left,
this is after the Weizmann left,
an angel of the Lord appeared to
Joseph in a dream and said, get up.
Take the child and his mother and flee
to Egypt and remain there until I tell
you, for Herod is about, so the fleet,
there's that word again, withdrawal.
Even Joseph with Jesus retreats
in the face of danger to Galilee.
And then when he hears they'd
come back, um, uh, in, uh,
verse 22 of the same chapter.
Now why is all this Jesus retreating?
The other thing is if you look at 10,
23 g,
we again get this same word when
you're doing an exit. Jesus,
you might want to use a concordance.
You'll learn on,
on Thursday or Friday in your sections
what a concordance is and you're learning
how to use it.
But basically you can,
a concordance is a word is a book that
takes all the words of the Bible of the
Bible and shows you where they occur.
And if you looked up withdraw
and an English concordance,
it would tell you every time in a
certain English translation that the word
withdraw occurred in Matthew, mark,
Luke, and you can test them out.
You'll also learn how to use an analytical
concordance even if you don't know
Greek, which will kind of give you
an idea once you learn how to use it.
What's the Greek word lying behind these
English words? And if you did that,
you could find out that these different
English words that I've been reading
from translate the same
Greek word withdrawal on a
[inaudible] on a car races.
And so this, this word is
here too. And in 10 23,
you have Jesus in his instructions to
disciples telling them that they also
should retreat in the face of danger.
Okay,
so what is all this going on? How do we
take these different issues? Jesus has a,
is almost a new Moses. Jesus teaching
the disciples should keep the Torah,
the law. Uh, but then Jesus,
when he faces trouble, he was,
he withdraws from trouble and he goes
off someplace. But when he withdraws,
he ends up preaching more and the Gospel
is expanding. And then to disciples,
Matthew believes will be the next version
of Jesus. They also will be threatened.
They also will be taught to retreat.
They also will then go preach and they'll
eventually go preach to the entire
world in the form of the gentiles.
So all of this is Jesus' first
functions as a model for the disciples.
The apostles and the apostles function
as a model for Matthew and the members of
his church. So what is all
this doing here and why is it,
what's the context in which this kind
of picture of Jesus would make sense and
we're going to spend a bit more time
on one important passage. Matthew 1422
okay,
this is the famous story called the
stilling of the storm. Now you will have,
if you remember this,
you can look at mark six 45 and it has
the same story and if you took your
parallel caught your parallel columns,
one from mark and one from Matthew
and you dig your little colored Pencil
exercises you had last
week for your section.
It's very interesting to see what
does Matthew add to mark story.
And if you figure out what Marc
Matthew added to mark story,
you can really get an idea about what
was Matthew's own editorial interests.
Why did he take something out of mark?
Tell it differently,
add new stuff to it that gives you a great
clue for what Matt do you want to say?
Because remember,
each of these riders is not just telling
you stuff that happened because it
happened.
They each are writing a book intending
to put across a theological message.
And if you compare what Matthew says to
what he gets from mark and see what he
adds,
and when he takes out,
you have a really good idea of
what his editorial messages,
what his editorial concerns are.
And we call this redaction criticism.
Redaction is just a
fancy word for editing.
And why did,
why did scholars not call
it editing criticism?
Because we like two bit words when
one bit words would work just as well.
So it's redaction. Criticism is
Rod, you'll sit in the scholarship.
It just means paying attention to how the
gospel writers edited their sources to
get up their own message. So
look at 14, 22 how many end?
If you want,
you can flip over to Matt.
Mark six 45 and see that change.
Or if you have Throckmorton, uh,
you can look it up and Throckmorton
some time, but here's, I'll,
I'll indicate some of it
immediately.
He made the disciples get into the boat.
This is after one of the feedings of a
bunch of people and go ahead to the other
side. While he dismissed the crowds,
after he had dismissed the crowds,
he went up to the mountain by
himself to pray. When evening came,
he was there alone.
But by this time,
the boat battered by the waves was far
from the land for the wind was against
them. Notice for the wind was
against them. The boat is battered,
the wind is against them.
Some of these details won't be in mark.
The basic story will be there,
but this is this thing about the
bolt being battered by the wind.
The wind is against them. I don't think
that's in mark, if I'm remember right
and early in the morning he came
walking toward them out on the sea.
But when the disciples saw
him walking on the sea,
they were terrified saying it is a ghost
and they cried out in fear immediately.
Jesus spoke to them and said, take
heart. It is, I do not be afraid.
And Mark Jesus and gets in the boat,
stills the storm.
And there they all say that Markin's
it with his own a clue that they didn't
understand.
They still didn't understand.
So that's part of Mark's
theme about misunderstanding.
That's not the way Matthew isn't here.
Notice what he says. Peter answered him.
Lord, if it is you command me to come
to you on the water. He said, come.
So Peter got out of the
boat, started walking on the
water and came toward Jesus.
But when he noticed the strong, when he
became frightened and beginning to sink,
he cried out. Lord, save
me. Lord saved me. Hmm.
Now the Greek word for saved
me can mean just rescue me,
save me from illness. But it also can
mean save me like I need salvation.
Same Greek word means both.
Jesus immediately reached out his
hand and caught him saying to you,
you a little faith. Ah,
that methy include. So He,
Matthew likes this little faith thing.
So that's one of the things you see.
He's added here. Why did you
doubt when they got into the boat,
the wind ceased and those in the
boat worshiped him and sa saying,
truly you are the son of God.
Now if you compare this,
what you've got is some important
different changes. First for example,
I said the boat is beaten by the waves.
That's not in mark.
Why did Matthew add that?
And then you have this whole verses 28
through 31 the whole thing with Peter and
all that sort of thing that's not in Marc
Mathieu added that whole little chunk
and then in verse 33 it says they
worshiped him and they had this confession
truly are the son of God,
which is a Christian confession,
a famous German scholar, Gunther born
calm. You don't need to remember,
and one of his students wrote a very
famous article published in the fifties in
which they analyze this story and
they said, if you read this carefully,
this story is not about Jesus walking
on the water and stilling the storm and
that sort of thing. This is a story
Matthew intends for you to see the boat.
It's almost a, it's a, it's like an
allegory. It's almost like an allegory.
The boat represents the church and Matthew
sees the church as being persecuted.
We've seen that theme throughout
Matthew seven Jesus prophesized,
the disciples will be persecuted.
So the boat is persecuted and that's
represented by the storm and the winds and
the waves buffeting him and
they're afraid. And Peter,
who represents every Christian says,
I want to be like you,
Jesus, and I want to walk on water. I
want to overcome all these problems.
He gets out of the boat,
but he doesn't have enough faith.
He has a little faith and his
doubt causes him to start sinking.
When he does that,
what should he do?
He should cry out to Jesus
and Jesus will save him.
And then Jesus gets in a boat,
calms the storm,
and they worship him and confess him.
So born calm,
used this redaction criticism.
He was one of the first pioneers of
using this method and calling it by this
term to say, compare Matthew
with what he gets from mark.
And what you do is you see that
what was just a miracle story?
Just basic story about the power of Jesus
has now become a moral story about the
church and it's now become something
that Matthew is writing to encourage his,
his own church.
They are small,
lonely people have little faith.
There are mixed group.
Remember just some people in the church
seem to have a lot more faith in other
people in the church.
Some people in the church may not
even be true disciples after all.
They're not yet perfect. One of the ways
that Matthew Chain Matthew has, uh, uh,
um, uh, saying that, uh,
is different from Luke.
They seem to both get it from queue.
Luke's version says,
you should be merciful as your
Father in Heaven is merciful.
Does anybody happen to know what that
comes out in Matthew in the sermon on the
mount?
You should be perfect as your
father in heaven is perfect.
Matthew has perfect and Luke has merciful.
Again,
we see bitty little bitty
clues of how they write this.
But Matt, that's Matthew telling his
church, I know you're not perfect now,
but God,
Jesus calls you to perfection.
They need more faith and
according to Matthew's story,
they do it by focusing on Jesus and
worshiping him as the son of God as they
should.
What I've done is walk through several
different passages. In Matthew,
an exit. Jesus wouldn't ask you to
do all of those things together.
You could write an extra Jesus paper on
just one section of any of those things
that I talked about,
but notice what I've had to do.
I've had to compare
Matthew with mark and Luke.
I've tried to figure out why.
Why did Matthew include what
he included and what did he,
why did any of that stuff,
why did he change things
from mark? I've also said he,
he probably used Q,
this a hypothetical document because we
find that we find that by comparing Luke
and Matthew and I might guess at how
whether Matthew has the more raw,
original version of Q or
where there Luca does,
and I might try to imagine what was in
queue and how Matthew May have changed
that,
edited that.
That's all of course pure speculation
because we don't have cue as a physical
document to actually compare it with like
we've got mark as a physical document,
but scholars still do that.
But the purpose is to all the way through
to figure out what does this author
want to do. It's not concerned
with whether he's telling
us that correct history.
We'll leave that for another day. And
it's not to say whether it's true or not.
And notice this,
it's also not to come up with sappy
Sunday school kinds of readings.
This is the worst, the hardest
thing for people to, to learn.
And it notice it doesn't matter whether
people have grown up in churches are not
modern. People have just come to
think that when you read this book,
you're supposed to get Sunday
school type sappy answers out of it.
What does the meaning of this story while
Jesus is teaching us to be to love one
another? Well, okay, yeah,
maybe so, but dig deeper.
Try to figure out,
try to imagine a historical context in
which a human author is writing the story
this way. In order to do something
socially in his own early community,
we imagine an early Christian community
and we imagine what problems they had by
reading the text and then we see the
text as being written consciously by an
author to address those problems. And
with Matthew, what you get is this.
Matthew teaches that a Torah observant
form of discipleship to Jesus.
Now this will be very important because
one of the themes of this whole course
is that is that dye the dye who had
the diversity of different early
Christianity's.
It's all,
it's anachronistic in the first century
to even talk about Christianity as one
thing because as we'll show,
there were different views of Jesus.
There were different
views of the Jewish law.
And what you'll see very quickly
in this course is Matthew has one,
has a very different view
of what Christians should
do with the Jewish law then
does Paul or Luke or mark or John
or several of the other writers?
So one of the things that makes Matthew
present a peculiar kind of Christianity
when judged by the standards
of Paul's kind of Christianity,
is that Matthew teaches Jesus as
teaching and a Christianity that observes
Jewish Torah, even in, even if gentiles
come in, which the gentiles do come in,
gentiles must be expected to
keep the law also. So we're,
whereas Paul spent his whole career trying
to get gentiles to say, to understand,
no, you don't. You're not supposed to
keep the Jewish law if you're a gentile.
Jesus absolves you from keeping the
Jewish law. Matthew is not that way.
He sees gentiles coming into the church,
but still being Torah observant.
So he has a Torah observant form of
Christianity with Jesus as the recognized
Messiah.
Gentiles are included in Israel.
They're not included as a separate church.
Gentiles are brought into Israel. Uh,
it looks like for Matthew and Matthew
presents a church that is in conflict with
other forms of Judaism,
whoever the,
I think Matthew was
written after step near 70,
certainly after the destruction
of the temple in Jerusalem.
That seems pretty clear. Most of the
scholars data to somewhere in the 80s,
maybe not earlier than the year 80,
maybe not let in the your 90
we're guessing on this, but the,
it seems to be it has to be after 70,
but he's in conflict with whoever
is there still pharisees around.
They're still scribes.
There are other people who are offering
a slightly different version of what it
means to be Jewish.
And that's the last thing that I'll
say about this is that Matthew is not
presenting a new religion.
He thinks what,
what we would call Christianity is
simply the right way to be a Jew.
So what Matthew's presenting
is a different sect within
Judaism from the form of
Judaism that's represented by
the Pharisees or the Sadducees,
perhaps some.
A lot of people think that this addressees
may have become extinct after the
destruction of the temple in Jerusalem
because the Sadducees were very,
their power base was the temple.
But if the Sadducees are still around,
Matthew's presenting a different form
of Judaism than they ex followed.
He's preventing presenting a different
form of Judaism represented by the Jewish
writer Josephus or Phylo.
But he is presenting a form of Judaism.
In fact,
scholars nowadays say Matthew not
represent a new religion with his gospel.
He actually represents
a different Jewish sect.
Any questions?
Yes sir.
Does Matthew believe that
gentiles should be circumcised?
I think so because I can't
imagine him teaching, um,
uh, completely law observant.
You know, when he says not one.
Dot or tittle or jot of the law will pass
away until I have an earth passes away.
Well,
any Jew at the time pretty much would
have thought that circumcision was a very
important part of Jewish law,
not just a dot or a Tidel.
So I think so you'll find lots
of scholars who disagree with me,
but of course they're all wrong.
Any other questions? Okay.
See you on Wednesday.